[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
das grundrezept für spritzgebäck wir
benötigen 230 gramm weiche mutter die
ich schon am vortag aus dem kühlschrank
geholt habe 100 gramm puderzucker 250
gramm mehl 50 gramm speisestärke
optional ein thema für vanille extrakt
und eine messerspitze salz als
allererstes gebe ich die butter das salz
das vanille extrakt und dem puderzucker
in eine schüssel und vermisste das ganze
miteinander
[Musik]
anschließend siebe ich das meer und die
speisestärke dazu
[Musik]
je nachdem wie weit europa ist kann es
sein dass die masse krümelig wird dann
gebt ihr noch circa drei bis vier
esslöffel milch dazu bis es eine
geschmeidige masse ergibt und in nur
zwei minuten habt ihr den teig fertig
und der kann jetzt auf ein mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
aufgespritzt werden auf mein erstes
backblech habe ich große flache kreise
aufgespritzt und auf das zweite dann
kleinere und etwas höhere und die werden
im vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad
ober und unterhitze für zehn minuten
gebacken
mein spritzgebäck ist jetzt vollständig
abgekühlt und das sind meine zwei
förmchen und die werde ich noch mit
etwas geschmolzener voll mit kuvertüre
und kokosraspeln dekorieren
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass euch das video gefallen
hat und falls ihr mehr davon sehen wollt
dann dürft ihr mich gerne kostenlos
abonnieren
bis zum nächsten mal auf liches kitchen
[Musik]